usually it should be actually easy to  track because you do have a transparent  blockchain fortunately in this situation  all customer funds actually just went  into one pot which is absolutely absurd  and that money went to wherever they  felt whether it's buying their parents  houses down in the Bahamas whether it's  being as you mentioned the second  largest donor to Biden's presidential  campaign whether it's putting on fun  parties down in the Bahamas for the  likes of Tony Blair and Bill Clinton  it's truly going to be impossible to  find out where this money went and  unfortunately I don't think people are  going to get their money back